[Musique]
qui parmi vous pensent que l'on peut
faire de l'impossible de sa réalité est
que l'on peut réaliser tous ses rêves
quelles que soient les circonstances
lever la main si vous êtes d'accord
excellent imaginez quelle serait votre
quotidien
si vous pouviez réaliser tous vos rêves
j'ai la conviction qu'avec de l'audace
et un état d'esprit positif
on peut tout vendre et tout faire je
suis sûr que comme moi vous avez déjà
entendu des centaines de fois ces
phrases mais c'est pas pour toi mais tu
vas pas y arriver
t'as pas fait ses études tu peux pas
faire ceci
t'as pas assez d'argent tu vas pas
pouvoir acheter ça mais tu rêves
lui pour qui tu te prends ça vous parle
depuis aussi longtemps que je me
souvienne j'ai toujours voulu vivre aux
états unis
je ne savais pas où quand ni comment
j'avais juste que ça arriverait un jour
et puis en 1998 je quitte mon job un
vendredi soir pour lancer mon premier
business le lundi matin combien de fois
n'at-on pas dit que j'étais folle que je
ne m'en sortirais jamais que c'était
impossible et je n'aurai plus jamais
d'argent une fois que j'aurai plus de
salaire bien sûr comme tout le monde
j'ai eu des doutes et pendant un certain
temps j'ai même laissé ces personnes
négatives m'envahir puis j'ai eu les
mêmes réactions
quatre ans plus tard lorsque j'ai décidé
que j'installerai mon deuxième business
aux états unis pourtant ça faisait des
années je disais que j'allais vivre à
new york un jour donc ça n'aurait dû
surprendre personne
mais bien sûr personne ne m'avait cru
j'ai même failli abandonner de
nombreuses fois et notamment lorsque
cinq avocats d'immigration deux ans
m'ont dit que c'était impossible
je n'aurai jamais de visas pour m'y
installer parce que je n'avais pas
l'investissement nécessaire ou parce que
le projet était trop petit mais j'ai
jamais abandonné et le 6e enfin m'a dit
oui mais c'est à tout à fait c'est
possible
coup j'avais enfin le mot magique et
grâce à lui j'ai obtenu un visa en juste
six mois à partir de là je me suis dit
ça y est je peux m'installer je peux
lancer ma société
dans 20 ans en fait tout est possible
quelques mois plus tard je continue de
célébrer cette nouvelle vie mais
malheureusement un drame allait freiner
mon bonheur on m'annonce que j'ai le
cancer du sein
alors autant vous dire que ça ça ne
faisait pas partie de mon rêve américain
donc faire quitter rentrer en france et
déjà abandonné mais c'est là où mon état
d'esprit positif m'a permis de décider
que ça n'était qu'une épreuve à
traverser et non pas une fin en soi et
que ça ne changerait rien à ma vie
ou presque après cet épisode
malencontreux
je continue de développer la société et
j'accompagne des entrepreneurs à
développer leur business
mais surtout à leur montrer qu'ils
peuvent aussi transformé leur vie et que
en fait oui tout est possible donc
imaginé une petite frenchie qui vient
dire aux américains que sky is the limit
comme ils disent que le ciel est la
limite
puis tout s'enchaîne et tout fonctionne
très bien
mais dix ans plus tard boum le retour du
cancer donc là de nouveau bien sûr il ya
des pleurs des peurs et des doutes sur
ma vie mais une fois le choc passé
je reprends la décision que je ne
laisserai pas la maladie m'encombrer la
tête et que je garderai une attitude
positive et que du que de ce fait ça me
permettra de ressortir beaucoup plus
forte de cette situation et c'est tout
ceci qui me permet qui m'a permis de
comprendre que nous avons le contrôle de
notre vie nous n'avons pas
nécessairement le contrôle de tout ce
qui nous arrive dans la vie mais nous
avons pouvoir des choix que nous faisons
quoi qu'il nous arrive donc vous
j'imagine également que vous avez
probablement eu des rêves et que des tas
d'événements négatifs se sont accumulés
pour vous dire que ce n'était pas
possible et que peut-être
malheureusement ça vous a peut-être
fait abandonner ou parce que vous avez
cru les personnes négatives
j'ai une de mes clientes qui a une
quarantaine d'années et qui est un jeu
qui a toujours eu des gens négatif
autour d'elle il ya quinze ans elle a
quand même réussi à avoir le courage de
braver cet entourage parce que pour
lancer sa société
malheureusement ces gens étaient
toujours en train de la tirer vers le
bas et lui dire que ça n'était pas
possible et quand il est arrivé dans des
périodes difficiles il enfonçait le clou
et lui dit mais arrête mais tu vois bien
tu as déjà expliqué que ça n'allait pas
fonctionner le jour où elle est venue
voir elle m'a dit vous êtes ma dernière
chance
si ça ne fonctionne pas avec vous je
devrais vendre ma société ou en tout cas
la ferme et vendre ma maison je ne sais
vraiment pas ce que je vais devenir
alors les trois premiers mois bien sûr
je les aider à développer son business
et développer des stratégies marketing
mais le plus important je vais montrer
aussi qu'elles pouvaient elles aussi
transformé sa vie et que en éliminant
toutes ces croyances résultats en trois
mois elle a triplé son chiffre
d'affaires est réalisé un chiffre
qu'elle n'a jamais réalisé en 15 ans
puis les mois qui ont suivi je les aider
à continuer de renforcer son nouvel état
d'esprit positif pour ne jamais se
laisser influencer
et surtout pour ne plus jamais se
laisser influencer aujourd'hui elle un
business qui fonctionne très bien mais
surtout elle a l'occasion de célébrer
aussi sa nouvelle vie et de l a pu
reprendre les des voyages ou des projets
qu'elle avait et qu'elle avait enfoui
parce qu'elle n'avait pas le bon
entourage autour d'elle alors comment
fait-on pour réaliser tous ses rêves
c'est simple il suffit d'ignorer tout ce
qui est négatif il suffit de ne pas se
laisser influencer
vous allez me dire oui mais c'est
peut-être plus simple à dire qu'à faire
en fait pas tant que ça il nous suffit
simplement de célébrer toutes nos
actions positives même les plus petites
et plus loups célébrons plus nous nous
rendons compte que oui tout est possible
et qu'on fait déjà beaucoup de choses
positives
en fait la vie c'est comme une pizza
qu'on serait livres à domicile donc
imaginer que là vous allez commander
votre pizza préférée et que vous allez
livrer dans 20 minutes chrono donc elle
va arriver dans la salle visualisez que
vous êtes en train de commander votre
pizza vous êtes confortablement installé
chez vous peut-être dans votre cuisine
dans votre salon vous regardez peut-être
votre programme tv télé mais vous savez
que vous allez passer une excellente
soirée en plus votre pizza préférée va
arriver 20 minutes se passe et le
livreur arrive comme prévu dans les
temps il sonne
mais vous ne bougez pas et vous n'ouvrez
pas il attend un peu il fait une
deuxième tentative
mais vous ne bougez pas et vous ne
devrait toujours pas il attend encore un
peu il commence à s'impatienter cet
homme et puis il ressort et vous ne
bougez toujours pas et vous ne devrait
toujours pas alors que se passe-t-il
non seulement votre pizza est en train
de refroidir mais surtout le livreur il
est parti avec votre commande
c'est une métaphore vous l'avez compris
mais ce que ça va ceci nous montre c'est
que souvent on demande des choses
spécifiques à la vie et quand les
opportunités se présentent et bien
étonnamment on ne bouge pas on n'agit
pas pire encore lorsque c'est sous notre
nez ou derrière la porte on ne passe pas
à l'action
ça me rappelle une amie maria qui est
une amie de floride et qui en fait avec
toujours voulu passer à la radio elle en
parlait tout le temps elle était obsédé
un jour où il rencontre une femme qui a
justement son émission de radio à
atlanta et qui avait vu une de nos
conférences et qui nous demandent est ce
que vous seriez intéressé d'être nos
invités donc bien sûr je pensais que
c'était l'occasion sautez sur le sauté
sur l'occasion justement et donc je dis
à mon ami écoute c'est super parce que
depuis le temps que tu veux passer à la
radio et en plus on va le faire ensemble
seulement il nous fallait à l'est
atlanta sous trois jours et là vous
savez que ce qu'elle me répond ah mais
non mais je peux pas ah mais non mais
trois jours c'est pas possible c'est
trop tôt non mais il faut payer les
billets d'avion faut réserver l'hôtel
puis en plus nommés j'ai les enfants non
mais c'est pas possible je suis dit
coûte
je m'inquiète pas je me charge de
l'hôtel on va être partie moins de 24
heures demande à ton mari garder les
enfants
et puis tu as pu le ton billet à prendre
en charge
et bien malgré son souhait de vouloir
depuis très longtemps passé à la radio
elle a préféré dire non et utiliser
toutes les excuses qu'elle a pu trouver
pourquoi parce que sa peur de passer à
l'étape suivante était plus grande que
son souhait elle a commandé sa pizza
elle a été livrée elle n'a pas ouvert la
porte
elle n'a pas pu utiliser cette
opportunité alors qu'est-ce qui nous
bloque en général dans ce cadre de
situations et peut-être que vous êtes
retrouvé déjà dans une situation vous
avez demandé des choses mais quand
l'opportunité s'est présentée vous
n'avez pas bouger vous n'avez pas vu
l'opportunité vous n'avez pas su la
saisir
et peut-être que vous avez utilisé des
excuses et généralement quels sont ses
excuses que l'on se trouve
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas d'argent je
sais pas faire
j'ai pas je passais qualifier j'ai déjà
essayé mais ça n'a pas fonctionné donc
je vais pas recommencer
est ce qu'au final ils n'arrivent pas
que de temps en temps nous ayons nos
excuses soient plus grande que no doubt
ma formule boostant temps si elle peut
vous aider à vous aussi c'est que quand
je doute ou que l'on me fait douter
je pense à ces quatre lettres wwd qu'est
ce que ça veut dire what good hope radio
que ferait oprah en français je suppose
que tout le monde connaît ou croit ou
pratiquement c'est effectivement une
femme qui a une enfance misérable mais
une expérience extraordinaire et qui est
devenu un modèle d'inspiration pour des
milliers de personnes dans le monde
rien dans sa vie n'aurait pu prédire
qu'elle aurait pu devenir la personne la
plus payés de la télévision américaine
et qu'elle serait nommé un jour la femme
la plus puissante du monde par cnn et
time
rien que ça
alors quand je doute ou que l'on me fait
douter ma formule et ww od et ça parce
que oprah est la personne qui
m'inspiraient ça renforce mon état
d'esprit positif
alors qui va être votre votre modèle
parce qu'il est vraiment important que
nous choisissions soigneusement et nos
modèles et l'autre entourage parce
qu'ils vont faire partie de notre
réussite alors en rentrant chez vous
installez vous confortablement
non j'ai pas pu dire de commander une
pizza mais pensez à toutes ces choses
qui pour lequel vous avez des excuses
est ce que ça vous empêche de faire et
peut-être que ça vous a empêché de faire
ou des gens dans votre entourage
est ce que je vous suggère c'est qu'à
côté de chacune de vos excuses vous
allez juste rajouter pour le moment tout
simplement vous allez rajouter pour le
moment alors de ce fait on dit plus je
n'ai pas le temps mais je n'ai pas le
temps pour le moment on ne dit plus je
n'ai pas l'argent on dit juste
je n'ai plus pas l'argent pour le moment
ses trois simples mots peuvent changer
totalement la perspective d'un autre
avenir et ouvrir la porte aux
opportunités dans notre futur car si on
veut faire face à un monde qui change
il faut déjà que l'on commence par
changer soi même donc si l'on veut
changer quelque chose si on veut changer
notre vie il faut déjà qu'on change
quelque chose dans notre vie michael
jordan a dit certains veulent que ça
arrive
d'autres voudraient que ça arrive les
autres font que ça arrive alors qu'elle
vote décision allez vous prendre
maintenant pour faire en sorte que cela
vous arrive parce que finalement vous
pouvez réaliser tous vos rêves
même les plus fous dernière chose
la prochaine fois que vous commandera
une pizza n'oubliez pas d'aller ouvrir
la porte
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]